I'll make a prediction the Rockefellers
were built on oil the new generation of
ultra wealthy people built on attention
you've got Mr BEAST's Mega amounts of
attention I think he opened up a
restaurant in a local area and had 10
000 people show up at a local restaurant
I don't think people still understand
because we as humans can't fathom or
comprehend the difference between a
million and 10 million because we can
barely even comprehend what a thousand
did there are levels to this game and so
I don't think people realize that he's
24 and media compound once you have tons
of media the monetization is the easier
part the question is is which way are
you going to monetize it you're going to
monetize with their endorsements you're
going to monetize it through companies
are you going to monetize it through
moving markets which when you're that
big you can do that there's so many ways
to monetize it at that point that I will
make a prediction that he will be a
sense of billionaire not just a
billionaire but a sense a billionaire